vous parle en attendant de de cette
arrivée hier soir sur le vieux continent
pour la troisième fois depuis son
ascension à la maison blanche joe biden
est de retour donc en europe nicole
bacharan bonjour historienne politologue
spécialiste de la politique et de la
société américaine des relations
transatlantiques vous êtes co auteur
avec dominique simonet de les grands
jours qui ont changé l'amérique aux
éditions perrin merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes donc notre invité du jour on
attend cette prise de parole au siège de
l'otan joe biden il est en europe
clairement pour resserrer les rangs lui
qui n'était pas tellement prise au
sérieux et il ya encore de cela en moi
lorsqu'il prévenait répétées de
l'imminence de l'attaqué en ukraine il a
retrouvé du crédit aujourd'hui selon
vous mais en tout cas ce que ruel
retrouvé du crédit ce sont les services
de renseignement américains puisque tout
ce qu'ils annonçaient s'est révélé
malheureusement exact donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand ils préviennent que
il est la lumière poutine envisagerait
le recours à des armes dites non
conventionnelles
malheureusement on doit le prendre au
sérieux et joe biden il bénéficie à la
fois du travail très sérieux fait pas
fait par ses services du fait qu'il a
décidé lui même de rendre publics tous
ces renseignements pour avertir et pour
tenter de bloquer malheureusement ça n'a
pas réussi en tout cas pour l'instant
les initiatives
russes et enfin c'est vrai qu'il est
très actif au sein de l'alliance
atlantique pour resserrer les rangs
entre alliés et pour essayer d'apporter
des des réponses et des réaction
coordonnée donc oui les prix davantage
au sérieux rock us et renseignements
américains indispensable aujourd'hui est
là à la résistance ukrainienne en le
documente régulièrement sur sur nos
antennes elle se limita à cela
aujourd'hui
l'aide américaine
l'aide américaine c'est d'abord le
renforcement de l'otan et ils veulent
fans et du dispositif militaire de
l'otan en europe il en être fortement
question dans l'es3 sommet auquel joe
biden participent aujourd'hui il y à
l'heure actuelle cent mille soldats
américains en europe au sein de hausse 1
de l'otan c'est évidemment l'an l'envoi
d'armes à l'ukraine et l'envoi d' aide
humanitaire et 1 1 milliard 200 millions
qui sont alloués par le congrès et signé
par le président pour l'aide globale à
l'ukraine et s'est également voulu
rappeler l'aide par enseignement à la
fois sur les mouvements de troupes
russes et sur les attaques cybernétiques
tout cela est en fait avec un certain
décalage qui permet entre le moment où
les renseignements américains capte des
informations utiles et celui où les
transmettent aux ukrainiens il y à un
décalage qui permet aux américains
d'essayer de de flouter de masquer la
manière dont ils ont obtenu ces
enseignements donc tout cela est
important même si on voit que c'est
encore insuffisant
voilà des renseignements qui ferait
notamment reviendra au terrain un peu
plus tard dans ce journal que
l'armée russe n'est pas encore à kiev
n'est pas non plus à odessa que cette
résistance elle elle fonctionne l as et
ses effets joe biden ce matin à ce
sommet de l'otan s'est dit favorable à
un renforcement des troupes sur le sur
le front est ce les fronts est et les
occidentaux
envisagent de livrer maintenant des
missiles antinavires à l'ukraine est ce
qu'on est en train d'aller crescendo
dans notre aide apportée aux ukrainien
volodimir zelensky s'est de nouveau
adressé à l'otan un ce matin par
visioconférence il n'a pas demandé
l'instauration de no fly zone au dessus
de l'ukraine il a compris hein je crois
pour le coup que cette requête ne
trouverait pas réponse positive en tout
cas lui ce qu'ils demandent aujourd'hui
c'est un appui renforcé un nouveau oui
bien sûr si vous avez raison de dire
qu'on va crescendo
dans l'aide militaire dans la fourniture
d'armes de plus en plus
forte masse il utile maintenant sur tata
faire de nos fly zone et cette affaire
d'avion je crois que tout n'est pas
complètement clair vous vous souvenez
qu'il ya eu une espèce d'imbroglio avec
les polonais proposant leurs mig en
échange de f 16 américains et puis
finalement non mais c'est typiquement le
genre d'arrangement qui s'il est
finalement s'il voit finalement le jour
ne sera pas forcément clamé sur les
toits je fait que les autorités
européennes notamment est annoncée ce
possible échange d'avion avec envoi de
mega l'ukraine a été peut-être une des
raisons du blocage donc je pense qu'en
matière d'armes ou de matériel envoyé à
l'ukraine c'est pas forcément la
meilleure stratégie de tout étalé sur la
table donc on ne sait pas forcément tous
à cet égard est ce qu'il ne va pas
falloir finalement ce sera l'enjeu de
ces grands rendez vous programmé
accorder les violons on voit bien qu'il
ya un certain nombre de niveaux on n'a
pas encore établi les réponses les
réponses de deux groupes certains disent
blanc d'autres disent gris sur la
question des armes non conventionnelles
notamment volodymyr zelensky dans son
adresse tout à l'heure a accusé la
russie d'utiliser des bombes au
phosphore en ukraine aujourd'hui il ya
le sol tonnes d'algues on attendra on
écoutera attentivement à ce qu'il dira à
ce sujet et sera sûrement interrogé
là-dessus a dit ça bouleverserait la
donne est notre réponse mais on ne sait
pas quelle serait la réponse de l'otan
si si ses actes si l'utilisation de ces
sommes étaient confirmés vous avez
complètement raison on ne sait pas j'ai
envie de dire que ça n'est pas une bonne
chose parce que finalement depuis
plusieurs mois avant même que
l'offensive russe ne soit déclenchée au
fond d'une certaine manière la dernière
poutine n'a pas été averti des
conséquences possibles les scellés par
exemple les sanctions qui frappent la
russie à l'heure actuelle n'ont pas été
annoncés avant groupe comme un
avertissement attention si vous en ici
et l'ukraine les sanctions seraient de
telle nature et il se peut qu'au fond la
nature des sanctions les surprises mais
c'était trop tard de même qu'elle est la
fameuse ligne rouge sur l'utilisation
d'armes non conventionnelles
on imagine bien que la ligne rouge c'est
celle de l'otan mais c'est
essentiellement aussi celle des
américains et là dessus joe biden n'a
jamais été clair la seule chose sur
laquelle il a été vraiment clair c'est
de dire il y aura jamais de trop
américaine en ukraine ce qui est un peu
absurde pardonnez-moi en matière de
dissuasion si on voulait dissuader de la
lumière poutine
d'attaqué l'ukraine même en ne voulant
pas aller sur le terrain on aurait pu
dire toutes les options sont sur la
table par exemple donc que risquerait
vladimir poutine en cas d' usage d'armes
non conventionnelles
ça n'est pas dit je pense que ça n'est
pas 10 parce que ça n'est pas défini du
côté de l'otan et donc ya pas de vrais
dissuasion est une autre question sur
laquelle on a vu aussi en plein flou au
tout début ce conflit on entendait dire
si la moindre balle la moindre rebond de
tomber en territoire en terrain de
l'otan il y aurait une réponse immédiate
on a vu il ya quelques jours à peine
qu'une zone à seulement 20 kilomètres de
la pologne avait été pilonné on a senti
là aussi un espèce de flou en cas de
menace réelle il faudrait qu'on se
concerte et qu'on établisse notre notre
réponse les positions elles ne sont pas
encore fixées à ce niveau là non plus
vous avez vous avez complètement raison
ce qu'on a cru comprendre que ces
déclarations c'était que les membres de
l'otan essaierait de vérifier si les
russes avaient vraiment une très
mauvaises intentions à l'égard de la
pologne par exemple ou si c'était une
erreur il n'avait pas voulu vraiment
frappé un lieu quelconque en pologne et
au fond ne pourrait peut-être pas trop
s'énerver la team c'est absolument
dramatique comme situation et c'est
d'autant plus dramatique qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui que les plus hauts
responsables de la défense et de l'armée
américaine non ne sont pas pris au
téléphone par leurs homologues russes
ministre de la défense et chef d'état
major
c'est totalement inhabituel même en cas
de guerre les russes et américains
soviétiques et américains maintenait le
contact pour éviter juste s'inquiétant
alors c'est inquiétant pour vous
aujourd'hui
éviter des accidents ou expliqué
d'éventuels accidents alors les contacts
sont maintenus à des niveaux moindres
mais dément - ce qui se passe sur le
terrain c'est des pilotes et des
mariniers c'est des officiers c'est pas
le plus aux commandes qui est qui agit
et le fait que le plus haut commandant
ne se parlent pas c'est très inquiétant
une dernière question justement nicole
bacharan concernant le niveau
d'implication finalement des états unis
dans ce conflit ils ont été les premiers
à alerter on les prenait absolument pas
au sérieux en un mois après le début de
la guerre est joy données sur le vieux
continent pour tenter de donner le tempo
mais il faut aussi dire que les
américains sont plutôt beaucoup critiqué
ici en europe ils ont pris des décisions
des sanctions économiques décisions
notamment sur le pétrole russe mais ont
dit malgré tout qu'ils sont encore très
loin et pas directement concernés par
cette crise aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que c'est plus loin
pour eux c'est géographiquement plus
loin c'est ça bouleverse moines public
que ça ne peut bouleverser les européens
même si caen dans tous les sondages
soutien très fort à l'ukraine et une
hostilité très forte à à la russie mais
néanmoins c'est vrai que l'embargo
américain sur le gaz et le pétrole c'est
un petit peu pris à la légère en europe
parce que ça ne représente que 8% du
marché énergétique américain mécénat 8%
américain c'est beaucoup et c'est un
signal fort finale d'autant plus fort
que les autres les américains n'ordonne
pas aux européens de d'exercer le même
embargo et vont essayer aujourd'hui de
travailler à mettre en place des mesures
de court et moyen termes pour diminuer
la dépendance européenne au gaz et au
pétrole russe et je rappellerai à cet
égard que depuis les années 80 depuis
ronald reagan les américains avaient
averti sur les constructions de nord
stream et nord stream 2 qui allait aux
européens ça va vous mettre totalement
dans la main des russes est
malheureusement là il vous avez raison
merci beaucoup nicole bacharan merci
vous était notre invité du jour a
justement il va en être question